Hallo mein Name ist Heidi.
Ich habe super Neuigkeiten für
alle Fans der Hallo Deutschschule.
Neu kannst du Mitglied unserers YouTube-Kanals werden!
Wie funktioniert das?
Es gibt drei Stufen.
Stufe 1 kostet nur 0.95 Franken im Monat.
Du kannst jedes Video eine Woche
früher sehen.
Du bekommst Emojis für den Chat!
Wir korrigieren und beantworten deine Kommentare.
Sstufe 2 kostet 1.95 Franken im Monat.
Alles von Stufe 1 ist inklusive!
Wir posten exklusiven Content in der Community.
Es gibt einen Livestream im Monat!
Stufe 3 kostet 5.95 Franken im Monat.
Alles von den Stufen 1 und 2 ist inklusive!
Du bekommst Zugang zu unserer Lernplattform!
Wir geben dir Einblick hinter unsere Kulissen.
Mit der Kanalmitgliedschaft unterstützt du die Hallo Deutschschule.
So können wir weiterhin jeden
Tag unser Bestes für dich geben!
Klicke jetzt auf den "Mitglied werden"-Button!
Für unsere bestehenden Abonnentenändert sich übrigens nichts.
Alle Nichtmitglieder bekommen weiterhin jeden
Sonntag ein neues Video und regelmäßige Posts.